Wesley anything can happen at the US CH
championships you showed that in this
game it wasn't an easy one it felt like
Ray was in fact trying to push for some
sort of an advantage but then move 40
came and that move Queen to E4 which
spoiled everything for uh Ray did you
understand that at that point you're
finally winning and tell us your story
about today's game yeah for sure but we
want to make it quick yeah so we can
watch M again
but I mean the game was the game was
very interesting I mean of course if you
look at any chess game with an engine
these days and you see like tons of
mistakes like you think oh I played my
best game and then then you make like 10
mistakes but uh I I
figured maybe that's the way the chess
is you know you got to take risks I mean
obviously if I wanted to throw it white
I could do it like I've done it a
million times before but uh I guess you
got take risks in order to win like I
was watching some games in the Qatar
Masters the other day and uh like Magnus
Hikaru they
were they were not better like 95% of
the moment during their games but they
somehow managed to win it in the end you
know like give your chances give your
opponent room for mistakes uh I I mean
it's impossible to be better I guess for
the most part all throughout the game
and then win very smoothly but uh yeah
yeah Ray just collapsed and blundered
everything during
the during the but I thought I had a
very
interesting position with this Pawn
structure probably white is not better
yes but I was very tempted to push my H
Pawn on H5 and then bring my knight on
H4 I thought I was had enough
counterplay but uh I clearly made some
mistakes like moving my queen maybe to
C3 it's a waste of time I don't I don't
really know mhm uh and I I guess like we
all just started blundering here Rook B1
minus three yeah it was this moment Rook
to B4 but again you guys were playing on
only a few minutes on the clock so this
is definitely not easy task so hard
thank you yeah you're so kind yeah I
mean I wasn't it wasn't easy to figure
out what was happening I mean I I I miss
some of his very good moves like B4 and
then C4 Knight C5 that was very strong
so the position was very concrete either
white is doing well or losing and I I
really had no choice at that moment like
I miss all this C4 Knight C5 which is
very strong uh then I couldn't really
figure out what was happening but um
fortunately Ray has always had um time
trouble problems as you can see from his
previous tourament during the
960 uh but uh also here like like I've
known Ray for a long time he's always
had that problem uh he he's gotten much
better obviously but I guess it's still
there so he' have a really good position
but then he'd try to calculate it all
the way in the end try to find the
perfect move and so it really cost him
uh today um yeah so it was a it was a
tough game you know Ray is a very good
very solid player you know his openings
well he's very difficult to beat uh and
uh and in a good day he's uh he can beat
anybody so well Wesley thank you for
being so complimentary I don't usually
get that from this uh panel right here
next to me so you saying that I'm nice
that makes me feel very good so I'm
going to return the favor that's where
I'm going uh I want to compliment this
final maneuver because it's very easy to
get tempted for about taking the pawn on
E5 right but it's not the way to do it
Knight to G6 Knight to E5 it allows
black some chances but he did find this
idea of Knight to G6 Knight to f8 so
that was very nice Wesley thank you yeah
I mean I I was very happy after the time
control to find myself in a completely
winning position like I was just trying
to make a draw but thank you Christian
you've always been so nice to me uh all
these years well thank the grand yes sir
are you
listening very kind yeah I hope the
answer is listening
yeah Christian always been very pleasant
all right we need to get Wesley more in
studio with us all right thank you
Wesley we'll see you in a couple we'll
see you tomorrow actually Absolutely
I'll see you tomorrow yeah our
congratulations Wesley